we're trying to prove that these
functions are even and this is the
function that you've got now by the way
I don't know about you
maybe you just started watching it - the
algebra mindless slave when I looked at
this question the first time that I
didn't write this sheet I thought really
what's what is an even function an even
function is symmetrical what kind of
symmetry is I have we gave a name
yes it's across the y-axis and you can
reflect the cross right so it looks the
same all on site as the other so things
like you know the classic classic
example I gave you was only 2x squared
sorry okay
but you look at this thing right and one
parts a log function and the other parts
minus half X then neither of these are
even right well are they a log function
what's a lot less of a fact a log
function normally doesn't even exist on
the left hand side right and then this
minus half X business is that's that's
not even at all it's not even okay so
it's a bit of a mystery how can these
two weird pieces come together and be
even if you you guys have got laptops
you're that generation so you can go and
open up the program on your laptop and
you can stick that in I can show you how
to type that up if you're not sure how
and sure enough it looks like that how
does how does that work okay
so it is even so how we prove it okay
let's just revise what did he required
required to prove to say something is an
even function what's the actual final
line which our conclusion yeah good
that's what we want to end up yeah so
I've got my f of X here so all I have to
do is say well what F of minus X and I
should be able to do some working okay
and end up back where I started because
there's
things should be equal okay so the first
step is just a straight substitution
right so I've got a log 1 plus and Q's
my first X so I'm gonna replace it with
a negative x and then I have minus X so
there's gonna be a double negative and
so I'm just gonna write that as a plus x
okay now I'll forgive you if you looked
at that and thought well now what
because there's a log thing and you
can't really it's not like you can just
break this apart I once saw someone you
know like this there's something like
this which is log x minus X and it just
sort of floated off on its own indeed
same name like sine and cos and tan this
is one piece okay so you can't just
break it apart so what do you do then
you do need to know some log rules to
end up simplifying this but my clue is
to think I've got to somehow get this to
the back like this again write this log
function in this log function obviously
have something in common so what can I
do to this to make it look like that
again
well there's gonna be some
multiplication involved right this is e
to the minus X so that's like one on in
the X minus X just think back to your
own index laws okay so across the way I
change the sign that's the way I
remembered it okay
so if that's one plus one on e to the X
I can bring that back to something very
similar by multiplying through by this
okay before I go any further can you see
I've actually changed anything I'm
multiplying everything there by one
right so that's why it was I haven't
actually mucked around anything I've got
my dicks floating over here okay
this hasn't proved anything but I can
actually start to expand this out yeah
and this will be a fraction on the top
so I've got e to the X plus okay e to
the X e to the minus X but I'm
multiplying them what I get just just
one right because it's multiplying it by
its reciprocal even though we're not
there yet this is promising because I'm
that e to the X plus 1 is the same as
that let's see the Xbox one as well it's
just okay all right now I've got that
part sorted but you can need to remember
your log laws to see well what my result
should have is in the fractions right so
how am I gonna get this out remember
with logs okay we've got the division
inside the log you can convert that to
something else does they don't remember
the rule yes so division inside becomes
subtraction on the outside and the Fluke
is also true multiplication on the
inside becomes addition so there's the
first part that's the numerator and
subtract the denote
okay and then I have my Harvick's yeah
okay now that was really the hard part
from here there's one more little rule
here I don't know if you remember that's
a definition by a definition that's X
but if you can't remember that you can
also use that power because up inside
there I can take it out front and it
becomes a coefficient
yeah so this can be let's put that
around the right way yes I can bring the
X out in front okay and Ln right that's
just shorthand what's it show I had for
ya good log base E it's the natural
number for a long one base B of e
there's my X okay so what's this thing
asking do you remember when you first
looked at logs you're really gonna get
into your head what is this actually
mean all the formulas of stuff it means
what power do I have to raise the bottom
to to get the top right two to the power
of what equals a and that's why that's
three right what power do I have to
raise e to to get a so that's why I've
got this up front that's minus X which
gives you suppose I should probably -
that's a bet
tada okay now there are a few things in
here that are tricky maybe maybe just to
really first you really got to know your
Volvo's right so you're going from here
to here and then going from here to here
remembering those plots that you can
simplify that and secondly you sorta
have to get this part it's kind of hard
to get just look like did that come from
okay remember I was trying to walk you
through I was try to turn this back into
that right you've got a multiply through
by something so that's why that was
gamma and B'Etor as much